is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status
symbol of choice i'm dave ramsey your
host anthony o'neil ramsey personality
number one best-selling
author of the book debt-free degree is
my co-host today
we'll be taking your questions about
your life and your money
the call is free and some say the advice
is worth what you pay for it the phone
number triple eight
eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five stephen is with us in
hudson wisconsin hi stefan how are you
hey dave ramsey hey hey how are you guys
great man
what's up uh not much i've been just
started listening to you guys
both of you actually um back in early
march
uh me and my fiance are both working our
baby steps we're in baby step two
so our question is we get married next
may
and we're trying to figure out how to
save that money for that um
or if we should start finding our
expenses and using that as part of the
snowball
uh because we want to run you know we
want to basically cash for
our wedding that's smart very small
congratulations
a year from now that's correct yep
okay cool how much debt do you all have
in baby step two well how much that do
you have and how much does she have
yeah i'm i'm i'm about 45
000 and she's a just under
just under 40. we've already paid off 10
total
between the two of us so far since march
good okay you're making some progress
then and
on that schedule you'd be debt-free
almost by the time you get there right
yeah
that yeah that's what we're really
trying to do we just know that we have
that coming up and we want to make sure
we're not adding more debt
yeah absolutely so what's your income
and her income
um i'm about 60 and she's about 50.
okay so what are you two thinking you
should spend
well we've already got um most of the
area started we're getting married in
montana we were able to save some money
by getting
married at a friend's house um and we've
already got a few of the more expensive
items already paid for
now it's just the finalizing um food
you know the catering side of things so
we're figuring i'm figuring between five
and ten
remaining um to pay remaining how much
have you spent already
uh about three thousand and so what is
she what is she thinking
um we're pretty much on the same page of
that it's our our
more of our concern is food because
catering can get
ridiculously expensive really really
quick well yeah i mean we've done some
done some big ramsey weddings and we
like a big party and
i can tell you from experience the
reception is the big ticket item
it's the most expensive part of the
whole puppy like all like all of it's
there
and so um uh just about i mean compare
percentage-wise so
um correct so you're you know i think
the thing is you set your budget and
then the food
conforms to your budget you don't set
your food and then make up your budget
yeah okay yeah okay that's fair that
sounds good
i could do with anything else you don't
say i'm gonna i'm gonna go car shopping
and then figure out what i'm gonna spend
yeah you go i'm going to figure out
where to spend and then based on that
i'm going to know which car lot to be on
yeah and then also too i mean i don't
want to kill the the wedding dreams and
dave may disagree with this one but
you know i think you and your wife need
to sit down and figure out what's your
priorities is it going into this
marriage debt-free is that the priority
or is it like hey
let's eliminate some of the debt and
have a real good wedding and then attack
uh the debt when we get out of it i
think you two sit down and have that
conversation
but in my personal opinion i love the
concept of paying off as much debt
and having a good wedding my sister got
married with no debt
and they had about a 5 000 wedding and
it was beautiful at a mansion
outside but the majority of the money
was for the food
but it was a reception and wedding all
in one so
have the conversation uh but i would
definitely figure out
what are the priorities and stick to the
priorities
going into the wedding yeah i think
based on that i
i don't disagree with him i i would just
say tinger your limit
yeah i like it i like that 10 doesn't
feel completely out of control making
110
right you're gonna get to between the
two of you you're going to get to the
debt
pretty quickly if you said 20 i probably
would be dialing you back down
yeah um you know if if i were and you
know the way we're talking this through
stefan is what we would do if we woke up
in your shoes it's not a there's not a
like a one smart and one's dumb but
you know so that the main thing i'm
wanting is to make sure that the two of
you really are in agreement on this
because i can tell you this as soon as
you start shopping the items and you've
already discovered this with some of the
things and that's why you made some of
the choices you've already made
the sky's the limit on what you can
spend
and so if you don't have boundaries
before you start shopping you're going
you're going to really
yes uh end up going yeah well we could
we could do a little more
yeah right yeah and here's what
yeah and here's what i love dave when
you set boundaries you'll
find what you want inside of those
boundaries yes yeah but you won't if you
don't
exactly yeah you'll get you'll get scope
creep
yeah you know on this thing the scope of
it will creep up and all of a sudden
you're going
that 20 thousand dollar card drive
better enough ten thousand dollar car
i'm just saying
and uh if you don't that this is how
people impulse
and he's not he's got yeah because what
he's doing is you can
tell by the way he's asking the
questions it's very thoughtful right
very intentional
there wasn't a flightiness about it
there wasn't a you know an immaturity
about it
so i think he's going to be real good
but uh yeah so i'm in agreement
with and anthony's grudgingly in
agreement with your dollar amount yeah
yeah
ten thousand he's trying to cut you back
to five bucks
but somewhere in that range is going to
be about right and don't let it creep up
to 12.
and here's but see here's why i said
five though dave because it's going to
creep up
and your 10 is going to creep up to 13.
no it's not if it's me
it's you know this i i there's a lot of
stuff i do but when i set the budget
done
that's the deal trust me that's the deal
i know man yeah it's
um it's a problem you know that
because you know and i think that's a
great question because it does
help us jump off into even a bigger
subject
anything having to do with the subject
of money
90 of people lose with their finances
because they don't tell it what to do it
happens
to them yes instead of them being
intentional and happening to it
right so when you get a guy like stefan
asking the question
yes and he's already put thought into
the process
yeah he is happening proactively to the
situation
he's not a victim of my wife
my my fiance and her mother are driving
us off a cliff with what they're
spending
yeah and we're in a reality show he's
not a victim yeah
you know everybody's being grown up and
is on the same page
and this is when boundaries actually you
know our budgets
with amounts actually work and they
cause you to become wealthy over time
absolutely and david we just did a study
and released it here uh
yesterday we found out nearly six out of
ten people in america do not even budget
right now
and so i can't believe and another ten
percent of them lie
yeah so it's probably seven or eight out
of ten probably so you know probably so
that's uh i mean it's just you know
people because listen here's the thing
if you don't do things on purpose to win
you almost never win yes sir winning is
not an accidental act
yes it's an act of intentionality yes
sir and
that's true of every part of our lives
and it's it's the biggest thing if we
can get you to do this with money
is just be going i'm going to make it
behave it's not going to tell me what to
do and i'm not going to wander into
chaos and wonder how i got there
so good this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 a month
by switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
so
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality number
one best-selling author
and host of the table on youtube
and as a podcast be sure and check out
the table
there are lots of interesting people
coming to the table to have a
conversation with anthony and
be sure you tune into that check it out
our phone number here is triple eight
eight two five five two two five if
you're tired of feeling stuck with your
money like you'll never get out of debt
or you'll never be able to save
it doesn't have to be that way you can
make progress
with money and faster than you think but
the only way to make it
happen is with a budget and that's why
you need a ramsey plus
membership you'll get access to the
premium version of our ever
every dollar budgeting app where you
plan out every dollar you'll ever spend
before the month begins this is that
intentionality that anthony and i were
talking about before the break
you connect your budget to your bank so
you never miss a transaction
you get custom budget reports and in
ramsey plus of course you can go through
financial peace university several of
our other classes are there
several quick one-off lessons are there
and when you budget and you get
intentional with your money you will
make progress fast and you can start
budgeting
for free today to start your free
trial at ramsey plus text trial
233 789
text trial two three three
seven eight nine alex is in los angeles
hi alex welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave it's an honor to talk to you i
appreciate you taking my call sure
what's up so i'm just
looking for some general advice here on
starting an e-commerce business
specifically white labeling products on
amazon
and i'll just give you a little
background on my situation so
i currently run an auto detailing
business but i broke my foot
and i luckily just finished baby step
three
and this month i'm able to get by
without dipping into my emergency fund
and still having a little bit of money
to invest in amazon
and i'm allocating exactly a thousand
dollars
to get this business going and i do have
good guidance around me i have some
mentors uh therapists
facebook group uh you know i definitely
have good guidance around me but
really i'm just wondering if there's any
general advice you can lend me
to uh you know so i can have my best
chance
at succeeding so what is it
um where did you discover the idea of
doing this
about a year ago i actually stumbled
across a youtube video that
it was marketing a software and
the guy that makes the software was you
know just talking about the amazon
experience and what it really entailed
and it really interested me so i've
actually
it wasn't just because i broke my foot i
wanted to get it started i've been
wanting to do this for a while
with that guy's software
yes so he sold you a business idea
um well it's this so the software is
something that you you do the product
research and you do accounting and it
helps you run the business
um but really what sold me was you know
him talking about
what the you know just what white
labeling entails and
uh so uh yeah i mean the
basically it was it was kind of the
culture of this you know
his company and the software and you
know the the facebook
group that i'm involved in also is a
group of
these people that are you know they they
also use
that software too but there's just you
know different amazon sellers on there
and uh so um but yeah i mean i can't
really pinpoint exactly
you know anything that sold me on it it
just sounded like uh it was just an
opportunity i got
excited about once he started explaining
it and uh you know the youtube video
okay well um
is white label labeling on amazon real
is drop shipping on ebay real yes
they're real there are real ways to do
that um
but more people make money doing what
he's doing than what you're talking
about doing
right um right yeah and so i worry about
how you got into this and what it's
really led you to
uh it's not to say the whole concept is
invalid
uh but uh
you know i i would not end up i would
not want to end up paying him more than
you are making and you're really going
to be close to that if you're not
careful so
and here's what's happening is you you
found a concept
and now you're backing into it and
really the only passion you have for
this is
making money yeah you've already paid
him more well
alex oh i'm sorry uh what'd you say
anthony
you already paid him more so actually so
basically what i paid for was the
subscription for the software
and it he sells a curriculum that
i had bought a year ago and you have
lifetime access to the curriculum that
teaches you the ins and outs like a to z
what it takes to do it
and um so i already i i already paid
a year ago for the curriculum and then
it's a yearly subscription for the
software
yeah well here's the thing i i am not an
expert on
white labeling on amazon i mean we sell
a
ton of product uh on on
all kinds of web based things and
amazon's one of them so
uh our marketing team does a lot of that
we don't do any white label on
amazon today uh we have we produce our
own products so we don't need to but the
uh
but they're products we're passionate
about and so forth and
uh so so what i would
the only thing i can counsel you to do
is is this smells like a get rich quick
business in a box thing that somebody
has promised you a bunch of stuff and it
just scares me the way it feels yeah
i'm not 100 so to where i'm ready to
just slam my fist down the table and go
you've been had uh but but i'm worried
about you
uh and so if i'm in your shoes based on
that
if i get that feeling and i'm in a
situation what do i do i get some more
information
yes about this and i'm not anthony i
don't know enough about the actual
subject to advise you
but what i can advise you is the life
and business acumen part of this is you
need some input from someone outside of
people dealing with this guy yeah you
need to find someone outside of this
guy's i was hopeful when you said the
facebook group that wasn't his facebook
group
but it's his face yeah so you're not got
anybody
outside of this uh
guy and his influence that's telling you
that this can be done
yeah and telling you where the holes are
and the upside is
and the downside is the pros and cons of
what you're looking at doing
uh so you need to get with some
e-commerce people that
uh that know more than i know yeah uh
but also
are not in his camp
and that's before you give him another
dime yeah
absolutely so uh um yeah we need to go
make some money now
so uh yeah so the i'll tell you what
alex
let me tell you what this lines up with
the reason i'm when i was your age
um i went to a
weekend or to a one night seminar on how
to get rich in real estate
and this guy was 25 it wasn't free
and um he their main pitch at that
seminar was not
how to do real estate their main pitch
was that
everybody's doing it it can be done and
for three thousand dollars this weekend
at our boot camp
we will show you how to do it and then
when you went to the boot camp
i didn't go but i know the guy that was
running it years later
i got to know him and basically what he
sold was
when you went to the boot camp the next
thing they sold you was well get in
our subscribe to our thing and when you
find a property we will buy it
and we'll go in partners with you and uh
and but you have to cut us in
and so it just kept going on going and
going and going in layers
instead of ever really just saying hey
i'm going to learn how to buy
foreclosure real estate and i'm going to
do it right which is actually what i
ended up doing
right uh aside from this but and the guy
got me started to his credit like this
guy could get you started alex
in e-commerce or white label uh with
amazon that are very real things buying
foreclosure real estate is a very real
thing running it through that system
where i paid twenty five dollars to get
to pay three thousand dollars to get to
bring him in on all my deals
yeah that i find for him yeah and he
puts up the money
ha ha um which never really happened
it never did i never found anybody who
ever did a deal wow i know lots of
people went to the boot camp and lots of
people signed up but i never found
anybody who actually got hit the guy to
put money into it
and um you know and then later on and
nothing down real estate he went broke
like i did i went broke too so
both of us went problem but you know
that you so the thing is you just
you need to get something other than
this guy's system because this feels
kind of like that
yeah i don't know if that makes sense or
not i'm not saying the guy's bad but it
just feels like that
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the ramsey show
open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five andrew
is in fort collins colorado
hi andrew how are you doing well
thanks for taking my call guys really
appreciate it sure what's up
so my new family and i are looking
to close on our very first home at the
end of may
in nebraska we're relocating to a more
affordable area
and to be closer to in-laws however
we got a call from our realtor yesterday
saying
that the home now has three feet of
flood water in the basement
so what we're trying to do is just get
some perspective like we're trying to
figure out
is this a blessing to say
hey you know what this wasn't meant to
be like we should back out of it we may
have to
negotiate with some costs that we talked
about with the seller
prior to moving in you know if we exit
but there
may be some homes in the area it's not
as hot of a market as
some of the other areas that we were
looking at or b
is this something that you know it's a
chance to renegotiate
the cost with the seller and or is this
just going to be this a mountain of work
ahead of us with three feet of flood
water i just
i don't know you know we're kind of it
kind of just threw us through a loop
because
we had a crazy 2020 and we were like you
know what we're going to be settled we
know we're going to be it's our first
home
got this nine month old and we're out of
the state but now we get this thrown at
us we're like okay
we just really want to think with
objective opinions and just
what's the best decision to go forth on
this yeah
so is the um the property in a flood
plain
you know it's in a low risk area and
it's
never really had anything happened to it
before it really surprised everyone and
our realtor is getting more information
and you know
there's a federal floodplain
right is it in a floodplain
it's technically not it's a 3 out of 10
score on the fema risk
that's the best information that i could
find um and our realtor said no it's not
and she seems to think that they've been
doing some paving
and like redoing of the roads in that
neighborhood and it may have changed the
flow of water and it could have just
been this
freak thing that happened to this home
and like one or two others
but we just don't know whether it's a
freak thing or not
you know now it's on the history of this
has been flooded
and you know we wonder if it's even
worth staying in or maybe it's just a
free thing and it's an opportunity we
just
we just don't know you are a brand new
married you have a nine month old and
it's your very first home purchase you
don't need this
absolutely not right
i'm getting out of it man
right now now you said i think it's just
that oh it's just a house deal
yeah it is just a house deal and the
house flooded yeah and they lost their
buyer
that's it now you said you may lose some
money
what money will you lose well it's not
much so like what we
you know they didn't have a radon system
installed and when you talk with the
seller and said hey you know if we
you know end up going to this home um we
love that a radon system installed they
said sure
you know we decided to pay that up they
were going to give us the credit at
closing
which is about twenty two hundred
dollars and um the rate on system is
only sixteen hundred and we said yeah we
pay for that
you know now and then we get that money
back at closing
we're just you know wondering would we
have to eat that cost and
and you yeah that money yeah and the
lesson you learn is you don't put
you don't put systems in other people's
houses
right you know you shouldn't have done
it that way they should have done it
period
if they wanted to do the deal got it but
um okay
if you wanted it that bad but um yeah
that's your lesson
right here but you know they they've got
a flooded house with a new radon system
in it bless their hearts
you know yeah that's uh uh it's just a
hot crazy market
it doesn't matter yeah it doesn't matter
your life is already crazy
you're moving you have a nine month old
and a new marriage
the last thing you need is a flooded
basement man absolutely man
yeah it's a week that was kind of my
instinct i just kind of needed to hear
that objective now
five years five years now today you'll
be glad you did not insert this hassle
and mess and clean up and potential
future problems
into your life while you have all these
other things on your plate that are much
more important
right even if you rent for a year
whoopty dupty
right right yeah we just because they
were saying you know maybe we'll lower
the cost
like significantly and i was like it's
not about the cost it's about it's about
you're you give up a huge chunk of your
life in an already chaotic life it's
about peace man
yeah you know you want peace right you
need peace
yeah right now if you call me up and
said i want to build a house
yeah i would tell you don't build a
house for your first home
don't build a house in your first year
of marriage and don't build a house with
a nine month old
this is a good way to get a divorce you
know but why it's peace
it doesn't mean it doesn't mean building
a house is a bad idea it means in your
situation
you are asking for crap you're asking
for trouble man
and just don't do that i wouldn't do it
yeah andrew i would just call you real
to say hey let's
get out of the deal asap yeah just end
it man i'm sorry
and start fresh and go look for
something that's not in a flood plain
yeah
or not a 3 out of 10 on the fema risk
even
all right alyssa is with us in oklahoma
city hi alyssa how are you
i'm good hi guys i have a quick question
um my husband and i just finished baby
step two
march 20th and we are on baby step three
but we are having a military move coming
up
um in july so we're kind of putting that
on pause for now but
my question recently came to me with an
idea of his
is to sell his truck that we just paid
off
um and downgrade quote unquote
um to a about a ten thousand dollar
less vehicle and i don't i want to make
the right decision and i just kind of
that's where i'm when he says gas
mileage and
it just it's not a truck because you
have a truck and so he wanted to
downgrade to an suv
um what kind of trucking why
no this is where i'm kind of worried suv
is not from a truck is not a gas mileage
move
yeah yeah uh yeah so from a it's a 2018
silverado and he was looking at a rav4
toyota so i don't know that probably
would change gas mileage yeah
yeah now that just how much does he
drive
um we right now we live we he's a drill
sergeant so we're very close to where he
works
um but when we move it'll be maybe a 30
minute
drive um one way um
i was not sure is he trying to use this
extra money to put inside of baby step
three
is that what he's trying to do yeah we
if we pocketed the 10 000
difference and from my understanding um
it would go to our
fully funded market we'd be done with
baby sensory so so you're like dave you
must really like the truck huh
uh it's my husband not me but
i think he he really liked the truck and
now i'm kind of
thinking it's a monkey wrench because we
just paid it off and kept
with it and now he's talking about
downgrading i don't know if he says it's
because he's seeing the big picture
and i just i don't want to just make a
decision very quickly and i don't know
if it's silly to
downgrade or just keep it i don't know
facility to keep a trick as well
when he says he's seeing the big picture
what is he gaining
by selling the truck ten thousand
dollars in the baby step three that's
the big picture move that's what he's
wanting to accomplish
pretty much he values that more than he
does this truck over a rev4
i'm not sure well that must be why he's
wanting to do this unless there's some
other reason he wants to do it
yeah i think he just wants a downgrade
is what i'm saying but
i know but there's nobody vaguely wants
to downgrade
i mean there's a reason absolutely
especially once y'all just paid it off
well how much do y'all
vaguely want to upgrade i don't vaguely
want to downgrade
is around 47 a year
[Music]
yeah you need to downgrade yeah he's
been actually listening to what we teach
yeah you have to you have a truck you
have a truck that's too expensive
yeah yeah that's what he's seeing yeah
you've got too much tied up and things
going down in value okay
i'm assuming that that's what's
happening is that he's a little more
plugged into what we're talking about in
teaching than maybe you are
because we tell people not to have more
than half of their income tied up in
vehicles and you probably do
absolutely so yeah i think that's
probably smart
he's right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
nancy's with us in birmingham hi nancy
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave thank you for helping us be
better stewards of god's money well
thank you i'm calling
no thanks i'm calling today with a
question about
what you would recommend for the amount
of an umbrella policy to protect your
nest egg
we do have two kids on our auto policy
we are
everyday millionaires and we just want
to make sure that we're
making a wise decision as far as total
coverage
i'd pick up another million as an
umbrella policy you can do that for
usually two hundred fifty three hundred
dollars a year
and uh just check with your uh property
and casualty insurance uh provider
whoever's got your homeowners and car
be probably the least expensive way to
get it
um and uh it's uh what that does is it
attaches to the top of
adds to the liability limits on your
homeowners or your car
so those those things stay in place plus
a million is what the million dollar
umbrella does
because as soon as someone discovers if
you if you're
if you're in a car wreck and someone
discovers that you have some money you
have a target on your butt
yeah yeah well that's what i'm worried
about so it's not based on how much your
nest egg is
no i mean they're they're you know i i
have had a million dollar i had a
5 million i got a 10 million now uh
so which nowhere near is sufficient you
know if you want to go
the size of my net worth uh it's not
even close but
basically what i'm buying there is
lawyers
right because the insurance company is
not going to want to pay out 10 million
and so they're going to fight to the
death with someone that
unless there's a true liability unless
their client me
has truly posed a liability but if
there's just somebody that's trying to
be an
um some ambulance chasing lawyer so to
speak that's
uh just they're trying to get money
quick and easy out of somebody
then they're not getting it out of me
okay
so we have two million currently do you
think that's enough then
as an umbrella i won yeah oh good yeah
that's fine
well what's your net worth uh about four
million
yeah you're fine you're fine because
here's the thing
that you're not going to lose a lawsuit
uh the the law
the light the likelihood of you losing a
5 million
lawsuit and not losing a 2 million
lawsuit is zero
okay so if you lose the two million you
know
the insurance company is going to fight
it and if but if you do something that's
completely negligent
and you know you're completely out of
control or something uh
and you cause a wrongful death due to
hit head-on dui or something like that
then
you know you're going to lose your stuff
and the amount of insurance in the world
is going to take care of that
okay right but the uh but if you're if
you're just
the main thing i'm after here is
somebody bumps into you
or you bump into somebody and they try
to act like it's something that it's not
not not a legit or even a small claim
that was uh
you know say a half million dollar claim
or something like that
you wouldn't want to absorb that for no
more than you paid for the 2 million
but a 50 million claim this is not going
to help you with that
right that's my point well i mean
if if your kid gets drunk and hits a car
full of people and kills eight people
and there's a 50 million dollar claim
on you um for wrongful death
then uh on your kid or whatever then you
know you got other issues that that an
umbrella is not going to solve
right okay so this is for this is for
the smaller
or the medium-sized ones the uber small
ten thousand dollars you probably got
that as a deductible you know so
you know you're gonna take care of that
anyway so what'd you pay for the two
million dollar umbrella
uh we pay i think 600 a year that's
about right
okay good i hadn't priced a two million
in a long time so that's good
who's it with you want to say uh state
farm
okay all right good yeah that's a that's
a very good price
it's not it's not a you know you're not
getting ripped off and you're not
overpaying by double or something like
that that's not a
not a bad price at all on a two million
dollar umbrella so good
hey thanks for the call open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five so anthony one of the
things we teach around here is that
once you start to do once you start to
build wealth you hit that uh baby steps
millionaire everyday millionaire status
you've got your million dollar net worth
we you start having to do things to get
rid of the risk
yeah yeah you got to play defense and
offense yeah
and um defense includes
extra insurance uh offense includes
high deductibles which keeps the extra
insurance cheaper yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah and
if you start buying other things like
you start buying some real estate or
something maybe you put that in other
names
other names uh meaning a comp open llc's
which is what i have my real estate in
uh and those sorts of things
and uh you know you're it's called just
risk
management at that point you're managing
risk spreading it around
so that the target on any one of these
things is small enough that it's less uh
it's less attractive for some attorney
to spend all their life trying to get
your money trying to get your money yeah
yeah
absolutely now let's say dave why would
you say cause this is some of the
questions that i get
like from younger people well why not
llc why not go get a
s-corp well holding real estate in
s-corp you can't do
yeah it won't work from a tax standpoint
okay um they're about the same thing
if you're running a business they're
very similar the llc
in some states is easier to operate yeah
but for holding real estate
uh you can't hold uh passive income like
real estate
income you can't hold rental in an
escort okay that has to be active income
like you're on like you're running a
business
right and uh rental properties different
kind different classification of
business so
you put your real estate into an llc
this company
ramsey his own is the lampo group is the
formal name
was an s corp originally technically
still is an escort but we rolled it into
an llc because of tennessee's
tax status oh they tax llcs differently
than s
corps uh and it keeps us from being
taxed
wow because tennessee does not have an
income tax exactly yeah but on the s
corp we were getting into all these
other side
angle taxes and stuff and we had to move
away from that but on the federal level
it's exactly the same
it's passed through to your personal on
a federal level i just learned something
but from state to state you do that and
so i've had
you know this company started as a sole
proprietorship which is my name my
social security number
yeah moved it to an s corp and then
later have wrapped that
into a an llc because of local taxation
okay okay local tax law so you've just
got you've just got to constantly be
looking at that stuff
as you're building wealth risk
management tax management all those
kinds of things start to take up more
and more
of your time um
to keep the government's hands off of
what you've off of money you've already
paid taxes on
now dave they'll go effort again so what
do you say to
people who are debt free have a half a
million dollars in savings and
investments should they still
start to start like start covering
themselves a little bit early
or wait until you hit that seven figure
i
i think you're fine to go because it's
200 bucks to get you a million dollar
right
umbrella i'd probably do it okay once
you start to worry about it but i mean
up until half a million i wouldn't
i would just not because most people
it's they're not coming after a hundred
thousand dollars
in a situation like that they're coming
after millions millions is what they
want or
they see a half a million into them
that's like hitting the lottery yes
uh and so it's um i mean i literally one
time i
i caused a wreck okay i was going across
a bridge
it was raining like crazy like it has
been today here in tennessee
and i was half watching what i was doing
and i slid and i hit
and i bumped a car from behind now the
car i hit in front of me
i hit them pretty hard not not like
super hard but hard enough
they were sitting still at a stop light
that it pushed them into the next car
the next car was this had a den in it
the size of a softball
i mean it that they barely got bumped
and they came for you and that woman
comes out holding her back like she was
dying
and she wanted more hurt than fly the
moon she just thought ding ding this is
my ticket
and uh you know the stinking insurance
company
my insurance company decided to pay her
against my
you don't have any rights they're going
to do what they're going to do because
they didn't want to be sued by her
and so they paid her to get rid of her
they gave her five thousand dollars and
she was not any more hurt than fly the
moon but that taught me
people out there you know because if i
get hit like that and i'm not hurt i'm
not gonna try to i'm not
i'm not i'm not gonna commit insurance
fraud no you know
but i'm telling you when it's the size
of a softball
you do not get a back injury okay it's
just common sense
so but people are out there and so
you've got to you got to be thinking
like she's thinking so it's very very
wise
ah that puts this hour of the ramsey
show in the books our thanks to james
childs our producer kelly daniel our
associate producer and phone screener
anthony o'neil is my co-host today
i am dave ramsey your host and we will
be back
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
thermzyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host anthony o'neil ramsey
personality best-selling author of the
book
debt free degree how to go to college
without that he can show you how he's my
co-host today as we're taking your calls
about your life and your money open
phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five monique
is in trenton new jersey
hi monique how are you hi
i wonder if you can help me figure out
if i can afford this next
move i am 75 years old
single i own my own home which i can
sell for about a third of a million
i thought i was going to stay here
forever it's a two-story home however
three months ago i suffered a one heck
of an injury
which made me rethink things and now i
want to sell this house
and get into a senior living complex
and i'm wondering if you can help me
figure out if i can afford this thing
long term
my uh assets my net worth is
approximately one million dollars
the initial buy-in for an apartment that
i like is about 270 000
with a monthly fee of 3000
that is going to be going up
historically they say
by approximately four percent
now my monthly income
is approximately thousand dollars that
includes
pulling out of my stock and bond
portfolio
the rest of it is social security and an
annuity
you mean your annual income
yes i'm sorry what did i say you said
monthly i was about to say yeah you
could clearly
afford it yeah so you have you got about
50 grand a year to live on
you're going to put most of your house
back into this deal and you're taking on
an extra three thousand what do you get
for 3 000 a month after you've already
paid for the apartment
just about everything okay all utilities
uh you get 30 meals a month all the
social stuff that goes on
now that's just independent living
they also have what they call a
continuum of care where you can move
into assisted living and then later
into nursing home or memory care and
those
monies go up assisted living goes to 55
fee a month 5500 a month and memory care
at 85
100 a month so what happens to the
property what happens to the property
when you die
they keep 10 of it and the rest of it
goes back
into your estate okay and they go up in
value i assume
no i don't think they do
okay no they're they're keeping all of
that okay
okay so now you can if you start to run
out of money the deal is they can't
throw you out once you're in
they contracted to take care of you
forever yeah but they're looking at you
they're looking at your net worth for
that so they know they got you covered
and also they're looking at that money
that they have up front
the buy-in money which they will start
to chip away from
in the event that you lose
the ability to pay so is this something
which is reasonable for me to think
about
they're asking what they're saying for
financial requirements assets
approximately two times your initial
buy-in
including a house and they want an
income which is you multiply your
monthly charge
by 1.4 now see i don't know what income
is
well sure it's your 48 000. so four
thousand four thousand dollars a month
and they want three times
1.4 so you're okay but
you qualify believe me they're going to
sell you this
um okay so
what is an alternative you know the way
to look at it is say okay what other
options are there
and um do i you know where am i at risk
and
what else can i do so if you bought a
similar property
and bought your own care for three
thousand dollars a month including food
uh but that property went up in value
but you'd have to mess with the
potentially you know
if it was a condominium maybe you had to
take care of the inside of it
the exterior is part of an hoa
but the asset doesn't you know it does
go up in value and they don't keep the
appreciation you keep the appreciate
your
your estate keeps the appreciation so
you're 75
other than this accident you're in good
health right
yes that's correct so let's say what 10
or 15 years worth of appreciation on a
piece of real estate
yeah so 15 years ago what was this 350
000
property worth i mean 25 years ago it
was 150. yeah
so they're worth 200 it's gone up from
200 to 350. it's gone up 150 in 15 years
yeah and that's you know that's what
you're giving up
um but what you've got is a system
and a group of people around you to take
care of you and all kinds of different
stages
so it's how much um
obviously they're running a business
they're not doing anything evil it's not
a scam
but this is one of the ways that elder
care
is structured these days and it
obviously has a profit built into it
there's no question about that and we
don't you know i don't mind a restaurant
making a profit on me i don't mind my
car repairman making a profit on me and
i don't mind your nursing home making a
profit
or your assisted living making a profit
on you we don't mind that the question
is just do you have a different way you
can do this
that'll give you the same services at a
better
uh transactional rate maybe not it
doesn't sound like it's
nothing's killing me here with the
numbers are you anything scaring you
with the numbers no
i'm not i'm not up i'm kind of like okay
out yeah what you're giving up what
you're giving up is a sense of control
and ownership yes yes that's true and
what i'm gaining primarily is
socialization because they've got five
million clubs
five so you can you can go stay in
another one if you want to go travel
you can just is that what you're saying
stan and no no
so they they've got lots of people there
that would be my age that i can say hi
to and have coffee
oh okay but i thought you said they got
five i mean
million clubs like what do you mean what
does that mean oh you're exaggerating
you're saying there's a bridge club and
a
so a bunch of social things on site okay
good lord i thought you were joining a
timeshare
or something i didn't know what you were
getting me too okay i was like
where are we going all
[Laughter]
you know what that's that's secondary
all this money that you built up is
first and foremost to take care of you
secondly yeah to leave an inheritance
right
we don't be wasteful and you don't want
to be ripped off
right but um you know the only
i i you know i've looked at these things
like 10 times i'm not an expert on them
so i'm kind of waiting in this like a
little bit newbie like you but i'm
looking at just the math on it
i think what you're getting is a system
and a process around you that gives you
more comfort than what you're paying
because i'm looking at this point
because this scared me badly
yeah the injury yeah the peace the peace
that you're getting
what you're giving up is what you're
giving up is the appreciation on the
real estate
yeah and uh and a sense of control
you're you're pretty much gonna do their
thing
at their price that's what they're gonna
do and you know you're stuck with that
so uh but you know just run the numbers
out and go you know
can i pay this yeah you can pay it and
it gets rid of food costs and utility
costs out of your budget
and housing costs out of your budget so
i it's not it's not bothering me i i
think you want to do it and i'm that's
part of what makes me want you to do it
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personalities our
co-host today our question of the day
comes from blinds.com find out for
yourself why blinds.com
is the number one online retailer of
custom window covering
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey
to get the best possible deal so dave
today's question comes from bill in
south dakota
he says we are debt free except our
house and have six months of expenses in
our emergency fund
we invest 15 percent and have the 53
thousand dollars
in non-retirement investments my kids
will be
in college after um i turn 59
i would like to help them with college
expenses by using our retirement funds
as needed instead of setting up a
is this a good idea no
i would not use your retirement funds uh
to so support your
kids i would still invest into a 529.
yep
yeah the 529 is going to grow completely
tax-free
so is a roth ira but you want to leave
that roth ira and let it grow
leave it alone and let it continue to
grow throughout your retirement years
tax-free
and so the 529 is a better vehicle it's
more tax efficient
for you than messing up your retirement
nest egg so anthony's exactly right
yeah yeah it's um it's seldom a good
idea
to attack to to use a
seldom like almost never a good idea i
would go further
to use the wrong vehicle for the wrong
thing absolutely
you know you just don't use a you know a
sports car to be a bulldozer
i mean you just don't there's a reason
that they're different and so
i'm making up something there they
weren't even good but that's good
analogy though
i mean you know you're just using the
wrong tool for the wrong
job and and if you're using a card or to
be a bulldozer you're hurting the car
and so and you got an inefficient
bulldozer exactly you know so
if your retirement is set up to help you
retire what you're doing
is you're only hurting yourself at
retirement age
and then you're putting more headache on
your kids
to now help you and so focus on your
retirement keep your retirement go ahead
and start investing into their 529 and
hey
what if you're too late right now what
if you're not you know ahead of the game
and you won't have enough to cover the
college expenses well sit down and have
a conversation with them
get a copy of my book debt-free degree
and put a lot of the ownership on them
focus on your grades focus on the s t
scores the a-c-t scores
and we can find the money to make up of
whatever you don't have
but do not sacrifice your future isabel
is with us
in san angelo texas hi isabel
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
awesome so i recently married the
my soul mate and sadly my soul mate had
lots of debt so we've been gazelle
intense about paying a car and his
credit card bill but we still have 90
000 left
in student loans and my question
is we have a rental home in san angelo
that is really close to angelo state and
i was planning
on keeping it so my kids could use it i
have five kids
and the oldest is going to college in
four years
so we're renting it i figured they could
live there
when they went to asu but
if i sold it now while the markets we
could probably get
out of that in a year
so i just don't know what does your soul
might make
i'm about 85 what do you make
i am just a substitute right now okay
so how long do you think it's going to
take to pay off 90 making 85
um at this pace three to five
but i'm just i didn't have any debt
except for my mortgage before the
marriage and so i'm just ready to
get back there okay and since
we're making headway right now because
we're uh
not being charged interest so everything
is going straight to the loans
what is your uh what yeah but what
what's your um fiancee do for you i'm
sorry your new husband do for a living
he works oldfield
okay now do you plan on being a
substitute teacher for the next three
years
well that's the other thing um i could
get a full-time job it's just that i
tried that at the beginning of this year
and my kids had they had to spend a lot
of time alone
okay and so i just decided to stay home
okay and now i sub at their school
i'm in a classroom with one of them
right now okay that's fair
well i mean the the trade-off is this
are you guys can he pick up any extra
hours where can we cut the budget
and get on a written detailed plan i
think you're debt-free in three years
thirty thousand a year out of
eighty-five is doable
yes and that's that's times three is
ninety yeah times three is ninety so
three to five is not an option three
is an option i like that um or sooner
uh by by cranking up something income or
cranking down expenses
so you're trading three years of
struggle
for this rental house
rental house is paid for right no
it's not okay what do you owe on it
a hundred and it's worth how much
uh my my realtor says it may sell for
180 right now
oh so it wouldn't quite pay it all off
then no not quite
and you're saying your kids can stay
there when they go to college
yes and you you know for sure they're
going there that's where they want to go
how long you been married
um since july
of last year yes
and everything's going good there
everything's great
i'm selling the rental you are
yeah okay yeah i want to because i want
to but he doesn't want to i want out of
that okay
yeah but he he's basically making you
lose your investment for his student
loans
so that's a bit of a shaming issue for
him but
we're not dealing with him and you
anymore we're dealing with you as a
couple
and what puts you guys in the best
position 10 years from today
versus what makes you feel good today
uh and and so i'm i i love rental real
estate i'm not gonna fight this hard
with five kids in the house
and live on nothing for three years just
to keep a rental property right
it's just not that appealing to me i'll
get another one later yeah
i thought it was debt-free that's why i
was yeah okay all right and you got
payments on it and you got a screw with
renters and you got a
and you got five kids yep so we got rid
of we got rid of hassle
and we got rid of debt and uh because
rental property is work i mean you don't
you have to mess with it and so it's not
it's not going to the mailbox and
picking up a check
it's not that simple so um now don't
take three years to pay off the
remaining debt though once you no do it
in 20 minutes
exactly yeah i mean we're cleaning up
getting every nickel out of every couch
in this house and we're getting out of
that
right now yeah right now very aggressive
very aggressive and then the part his
part of it is
that you guys say okay as these kids go
back to school as these kids go off to
college
well let's try to get in a position we
can just pay cash for a rental over
there yeah
and put them in it if it's across town
yeah uh but um you know there's no
requirement
listen i own a bunch of real estate
zero ramsey kids stayed in one of my
properties
while they were in college zero i did
not go to knoxville 200 miles away and
start buying properties
to put college kids in i just put them
in there
daniel and i were talking about lunch at
breakfast this morning my son and i have
breakfast he goes
you remember that old ratty house we
rented and you wouldn't let me co-sign
so we pre-paid the rent
i'm like yeah because i'm not i'm not
signing a co-signature and neither are
you
that's a lot more dangerous than prepaid
rent so i just you know i paid his
portion of the rent for uh
uh uh two semesters and then he was on a
budget you know
we were supporting him going to college
and he you know his portion wasn't that
much
it was uh 2-300 bucks a month or
something because it was not a fine
property
and by that i don't want to be the
landlord of that bunch of goobers
i mean do you want to be their landlord
no but it's like
college boys in one house shoot me and
get it over with there's smells there
you'll never get rid of
as a father that as a wealthy father i'm
just surprised to hear you say that dave
because most wealthy people will be like
yeah i bought a house that's cool
yeah but i mean the thing is then i got
to get rid of it and i got to deal with
the crap
i got you know i got to detox it that's
fair
no i'll just let somebody else deal with
that a little bit of rent money's a
cheaper that's a cheap out man
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
how many of you when the pandemic was
going and 2020 is happening
and you're watching the roller coaster
of the stock market
you kind of got your stomach up into
your throat going i
my retirement i'm scared
some of you you watched it go down and
then you watched it come back up and
maybe you're close to retiring and
you're wondering if you should work a
few more years to make up the difference
maybe you weren't investing in the right
things or maybe you weren't investing at
all or maybe you pulled your money out
which is really stupid
see folks if you're in one of these
situations i want you to know you don't
have to face this pain
and this uncertainty alone you need
people in your corner now more than ever
seek out the advice of an investment
professional
a conscientious investment pro like one
of our smartvestor pros
is not going to tell you to invest in
something dumb
like gold or bitcoin they're going to
spend a ton of time
looking at your current situation
putting you in a conservative
investment with a proven long-term
track record and they're going to show
you what you're doing and teach you
so you're making the real decision you
don't have to let something like 2020
kill your confidence
for investing go to ramseysolutions.com
smart vester find an investment pro in
your area
never again face a global crisis alone
ramsey solutions dot com smart vester
so anthony the stock market dove a year
ago
and in a matter of a couple months it
was back
and the people that dove out of the
stock market when they
because they were at home being
quarantined one year ago
right now are upset were freaked out
yep and they thought oh this pandemic is
truly the end of the world
the stock market i mean you know they
were really there was terror there was a
lot of
real fear yes and you and i are undoing
a lot of media then all the ramsey
personalities we're doing
streaming events out of here the message
of hope went out we did all these
different things trying to get people to
calm down and just go
back up pan out have a long-term
perspective
this too shall pass and it passed from
an investment perspective
faster than the actual virus passed
absolutely i mean i
i thought the investments might take a
year to come back and the kova to be
gone
in a month yeah and it's quite the
opposite yeah it's taken a year to get
the covet stuff
out of most people's systems it's not
out of everybody's system yet right
and uh uh but the investments have been
back a long time yeah
they came back quick and if you have all
the data tells us that if you have a
professional in your corner that talk
you off the ledge keep you from
panicking
that you have a higher probability of
making money it's not that their
investments necessarily are better than
you would have picked on your own right
it's that you don't jump off a cliff
absolutely you know my investor today
when i when i called my
uh smart investor he said hey and this
is something i've heard you say but he
said do not forget
on paper yes it's going to go down but
when you take it out that's permanent
it will go back up it has to go back up
and he said
i he said it was probably like around
last september
he suspected it will be back up within
eight months and and dave it went right
back
up and the numbers were very well and i
remember all of us
begging people do not touch your
investments do not touch your 401k
even though the government was giving
you a way out do not touch your roth
iras do not touch none of the stuff
and now i have friends who have called
me and said i messed up
yeah oh yeah yeah they wouldn't they
wouldn't listen to you wouldn't no
listen to me wouldn't you know it's like
and that's
your your smart mr pro was correct when
it goes down and you sell
you actually have locked in we call it
you locked in your losses
you guaranteed that you're going to lose
money yes sir because you just did
yeah you know and so versus i remember
uh
somebody said to uh warren buffett one
time his you know the price of the stock
portfolio that he had went down
uh several billion dollars uh in a you
know in one of these downturns
and they said you know mr buffett you
you just lost several billion dollars
and he said
no i didn't hold the old paper
i haven't sold it yeah when i sell it
that's when i've lost it yep
when it comes back up and did i gain it
you know no not until i
you know you did you make several
billion no not till i sell it right
you know so it's just you know you and
me anything until you
actually put the money in your pocket or
put the loss in your pocket and lock it
in
yeah and so you know but the the data
tells us
that just like having a personal trainer
gives you a better chance of winning
just like having a coach inside ramsey
plus gives you a better chance of
finishing your dead snowball yeah
a smart investor pro in your corner
gives you a better chance of staying in
the investment which is actually the
statistical key
yeah the secret sauce is not figuring
out the perfect investment the perfect
so the secret sauce is keep investing
and never stop never stop
yep and also one of the secret sauce
david i think which i love hearing you
you know even at your level of status
you still have a smart investor pro that
just educates you on certain things when
you meet with them on a yearly basis
and i was like man i'm constantly
learning
even when i was even a little fearful
myself last year dave i said all right
cool i'm gonna trust dave i'ma trust you
all
i'm not gonna touch this thing and dave
i'm i'm trying to tell you even a small
fear that did hit me for a quick second
i ain't gonna say sure sure
no it does i mean it hit you're not
human if you're not facing some big
blow up thing like a pandemic and you
don't go oh my god what's happening here
yeah i mean in 2008 i remember
distinctly
sitting i had done three shows on fox
yeah in new york and the the stock
market has gone off a cliff
i mean it went from thirteen thousand
sixty five hundred i mean it's going off
a cliff and i remember sitting in the
steak house there right next to fox
sharon and i went over there for lunch
after i just finished neil cavuto and
i've been in there with neil neil smart
as a way up and
he's like aren't you scared i'm no i'm
not scared no i'm not scared i kept
saying no i'm not scared
and then i'm sitting there in that in
new york city in this steakhouse and i'm
watching these big red letters go across
the side of the fox building watching
the stock market drop
minute by minute by minute it's dropping
and i know this stuff
i teach this stuff right i'm going every
people that are smarter than me are
scared maybe i should be scared
and i said sure am i dumb we're not
being scared and she said no
we actually know what we're doing we've
been through these kinds of things
before
and we're people of faith we don't place
all of our
all of our happiness based on the size
of our stinking bank account exactly
anyway and we've been broke before and
we didn't lose our minds then we could
be broke again and we'll
be all right but we're not going to be
broke it's going to be okay yeah
yeah i mean and that's how i felt too
dave honestly i was oh okay get over
this fear and
keep on moving and i'm so grateful that
i didn't do it great so great grateful
my family didn't do it but i i have to
be honest
i was sad and hurt that my friends
didn't listen
yeah well you got to have somebody in
your corner to talk you off the ledge
that's what it comes down to
jude is in tampa florida hi jude how are
you
how you doing mr ramsay mr neil i'm good
great man how can we help
great uh well i find myself actually in
a good situation just looking for a
little bit of advice
um currently my take-home household
income
is 150 000 a year uh
about 83 000 of that between
a military pension and va benefits and
then the rest between myself and my
wife's
jobs i'm about to change jobs
this coming summer within the next
couple months just don't have a firm
date yet
and i am debt-free except for uh our
house
which is we owe about 258 on the
mortgage
so my question is the job that i'm going
into
the 401k that they offer without me
having to contribute
they do 15 um
so i already contribute to my retirement
15
of everything good my question is is
can it would it be wise at all i really
want to pay off the house
to just contribute 15 of my non-pension
income because that pension is going to
be there you know for my life
um would i be able to just contribute to
15
of the non-pension income and the money
that i'm saving
dump all that on the house to get the
house paid off quicker
dude you're a grown man you're able to
do whatever you want to do
okay well i'm looking for some advice as
far as what you would recommend i would
recommend putting 15
of your income into retirement
absolutely and all these other things
just because the answer to the question
is how rich do you want to be
right right okay you know i mean
i i don't want to be quite as wealthy
okay well then
no i mean you're putting it all towards
the house so it is going to work out but
um
but the interesting thing is is that you
won't change the date
you pay off your house but by one year
by doing all this
wow maybe two years
but you're not gonna change it by eight
years and so it's not changing it as
much as it feels like in your emotions
it's going to change it
so you can do whatever you want to do
obviously we recommend you put 15
of your income away take your kids
college and baby step five and pay off
your house with anything you can scrape
up past those two and baby step six
and i don't think it's going to change
your house payoff date as much as you
think it's going to change it when you
run out the math actually
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america anthony
o'neil ramsey personality is my co-host
today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five amy
is with us in cincinnati hi amy welcome
to the ramsay show
hi thank you very much um i just have a
question i'm
uh my brain just keeps shutting down
when i try to process it
where i live in ohio we are
putting our will together with the mom
of their legal forms
but our son is incarcerated in a
different state
and that's where i sort of hit
the block of i'm not really sure
how to deal with that in our will like
it'll be a few more years and if
something happened before then i'm not
sure
how that works okay
so um what you're saying i think is is
that you should want to leave him money
anyway but you don't know how
how it will be handled while he's
incarcerated
right and then when yes
yes okay so you're you don't have any
question about
whether to leave him money or no based
on him
based on his crime or his life or
anything else
it's just how to do it how to do it okay
all right how much uh how much longer is
he incarcerated amy
um at least probably three
more years okay and um
i've been modeling this over for two
years already
like i've got to get this done in case
something you have you have other
children
i do yeah two they're all grown
they are all grown yes okay
um a couple properties and
we're everyday millionaires but um
i'm just not sure you know how to
how to proceed with him incarcerated
in another state well the other state
doesn't matter he doesn't need money
now right and he would need access to it
on a limited basis however you want to
limit it coming out
um how is his relationship with his
siblings
um it's good so they are as supportive
as you are
yes okay why don't you just leave his
portion in trust
uh with one of your one of your other
kids as the trustee
okay and then that trust could be
dissolved at
uh on whatever terms you wanted it to be
dissolved
um if you feel like he's responsible
enough to just be handed the money when
he walks out of
jail which feels a little weird but i
don't know what he did or what's
what's going on so it's hard for me to
tell but uh
i would want to protect him from himself
right blowing the money right
blowing the money but uh how old is he
uh 23. okay
so yeah i i don't uh i guess could
i could get a neutral person if not one
of his siblings i don't want
anything to have to fall on one of his
siblings
you know uh as far as managing it but
well you can you know
you may if you want to get that if you
want to get that complicated you may
want to get an attorney to draft this
and you can set the attorney up as the
trustee
oh okay a state attorney estate
attorneys often serve as trustees
okay and so then you just divide
everything up into
his third goes in the trust and then
that
exactly that's right or whatever you're
going to leave him can go into trust and
it could just simply sit there and be
managed for his benefit until he's
released and then it's turned over to
him or it's turned over him a little bit
at a time after he's released however
you prefer
to do that right but you're going to
leave this kid a half million dollars it
sounds like
um probably around there yeah
so on the actual physical property like
house
and things like that i've been told that
you should
have it on death the being transferred
to
like one of our kids
yes
yeah i wouldn't put them on the deed but
you can just you can have a transfer to
them upon death
okay that gives them a stepped-up basis
in it and you don't want to
okay you do not want to put their name
on it prior to death
right okay so just haven't transferred
to them upon death
yeah yeah and okay hopefully you've got
properties that you don't have to have
them being
like partners in that you can give one
on one property one of them the other
property and so on right
right right yes that's how it's
it is yeah and then kind of even it even
it out even out the differences with
cash right
right right because they don't want them
to have to get into
yeah all that i'm curious
uh because you seem very very sure
that at a he's 23 he'll be 26 when he
gets out
that he's going to be capable of
managing this and yet he did something
that landed him in jail what'd he do
um well it was um
he went off his medication and
committed a felony so but
normally this is not an issue
there's been but it's all he's
medication what was he on medication for
um for um
like the depression and i know
that's okay he's bipolar yeah okay uh
yeah
that's part of it and so it was just uh
okay i'm trying i'm trying to think with
you here i'm not trying to shame him or
you
i'm just trying to think with you how we
can best be a blessing to this young man
because the last thing because money
magnifies
people the good and the bad in them
right and uh so in all of us it happens
so the more money you get the more
you are of who you are uh because you
got more power to do things with and
more margin more tools in your hands and
so
uh i would if i were you i would
consider prayerfully something like he
needs to have six months after he's out
that he's on his medication yeah right
because it's not it's not gonna be good
for him to have a half million dollars
if he's off his medication
nope right because last time he was off
his medication it wasn't good you know
this
kind of thing because i i don't want him
i don't want this to be a curse to him
rather than a blessing
right that's all i'm thinking i agree so
think of think through some ways how you
can
help him be protected against himself
until he has the
character structure or whatever to carry
this yeah and you know what dave i was
um
going to chime in you know unfortunately
i have a cousin that
was in a similar situation and his
mother
uh left him some money and she did for
five years
every one year anniversary he had access
to more money
yeah yeah and so i mean and it worked
for him now unfortunately after the
fifth
year uh he made some more bad decisions
and landed back in jail but i agree with
you that if he
gave him the best shot exactly yeah that
gives them a bit a gradual thing
because otherwise you get lotto syndrome
yeah when somebody you know you come out
of jail and you got a million dollars
you feel like you hit the lotto yeah
yeah
and um you know
and it it doesn't bode well for the
mental illness that he's struggling with
so uh you need to get on top of that
because you're always going to have
money problems and
other problems too obviously as long as
you do that so it's a struggle but i
mean
listen to this mother's heart though
like very sweet he messed up i still
want to be a blessing sure that's very
sweet i got no issue with that at all
i'm not saying i'm not trying to punish
somebody further that's not the point
the point is to do the opposite to make
sure that we're not
um enhancing their ability to screw up
is there like a is there like a law dave
because i'm not familiar with this but
can
can you extend it like a long period of
time like over 15.
whatever you want on the trust ah you
can put you never get the money you can
only take the income off of it your
entire life
that's where trust fund baby comes from
yep they live off the money of the trust
fund but they never get the trust yep
that's where the concept comes from yeah
so yeah it's you can set it up however
you want i wouldn't recommend that
though yeah
i think that's uh it doesn't bode well
for everybody involved
at some point the people need to be able
to carry the weight
of the wealth without it being a damage
to them or they need to relinquish it
one of the two
this is the ramsey show
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's
the ramsey show where debt is dumb cash
is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host this is a small
business
entree leadership theme hour if you own
and operate a business or you're a
leader in a business and you want to
talk
small business any questions you've got
about business this is your hour we're
going to talk to you
because you are heroes you are the
backbone
of the american economy
most of the jobs in america
are provided by you most of the job
growth
is provided by you you were the last to
shut down and the first to open
up because you have to
you don't have a choice you get up every
day
you leave the cave you kill something
and you drag it home
and at ramsey we love entree leaders we
are entre leaders
the combination of entrepreneurs and
leadership that's where i got that name
i made it up and it's the title of a new
york times best-selling
book number one best-selling book
entree leadership how to own and operate
a business it's our playbook of how we
run
ramsey and uh continues to evolve
as we take on new challenges running
ramsey
new things to run ramsey with and so
we're here to help you today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five you guys make the world go
around out there
you gals make the world go around out
there the ones that do this
are are the place that this is the free
enterprise system
your proof that capitalism is alive and
well
that the free enterprise system works
and we love you for that
so we're here to help you today triple
eight eight two five five
two two five amy's with us in hayes
kansas hi amy
welcome to the ramsay show hi how are
you dave
better than i deserve what's up in your
world well i have a question
i am a small business owner and i'm
wondering to know
when to quit my full-time job and follow
my massage therapist career
i'm wondering if this is a good economy
to depend
solely on my business my full-time job
has a 401k
that matches up to six percent and has
really good health insurance
i can get health insurance through
healthcare.gov
healthcare.gov or chm though is staying
with my full-time job worth the six
percent matching funds on my 401k
currently i'm okay no you go live your
dream you don't keep a job for benefits
currently now what you do have to have
is you have to have money
okay so you can't be making three
dollars as a massage therapist and walk
away from 103 000 as a job
no i don't i make i make just as much
with my massage therapy as i do my my
full-time job
how much i make um
last year through my taxes i made 43
595 at my full-time job
in massage therapy i did have to close
for two months
so i only made 38 153 but the last year
i made
the exact pretty much the exact same
amount and are you single it sounds like
you are
no we i'm married okay so what does your
husband make
he makes um he's actually retired this
year
what does he make he makes uh 36 000 a
year
okay so if your income goes from
a hundred thousand to
seventy thousand are you going to be
okay because that's what's gonna happen
uh yeah we're we're actually taking
doing the baby steps now and we're in
baby step two
and we should have baby step two done in
june
okay well it'd be good to have that done
and have the emergency fund in place
right
right yeah and then so probably a
september kickoff or something like that
but and here's the thing obviously
you're going to make more than 38 000 at
massage therapy because a you'll be full
time and b
you don't have the pandemic to deal with
like you did last year right
correct yes okay so kansas is open you
got
no you gotta not have any issues except
for the handful of people who are
freaked out still right
yes exactly okay cool good for you
very good well i mean you're going to
see a drop because you've been running
this
side hustle that's very profitable and
you're going to lose the full-time
income and be down to the side hustle
income but you're at the point you
should do this
okay yes in september you should do this
and between now and september you should
go bananas
and pile up as much money as you can
pile up and be debt-free
okay and just set yourself a goal of
september one my emergency fund is
complete and then some
extra just for the fun of it and because
we're just going to go bananas here
through the summer
and we're going to be debt-free have a
big emergency fund plus a little extra
slush
and um then we're going to go boom boom
and
and go ahead and have a big marketing
launch and a blowout plan
to go to go big or go home september
october november december
uh like i want all of your customers
giving certificates for your services as
christmas presents next year all of them
you need marketing plans uh yes i have
that already
started you're fine you're going to do
this you're incredible
well thank you get them i love it see
that right there is what causes business
to happen
right there and listen folks there is
no benefit on the planet that causes you
to want to work for somebody else the
rest of your life if you have in your
gut to be an entrepreneur
listen i can i i love the folks we have
a thousand people on our team i got some
people be with me the rest of their
lives here and i hope they are
and they're very entrepreneurial inside
this building and they're happy with
that
i don't want anybody staying here
because we got a good 401k plan you need
to go
if this is not your dream anymore go
dream somewhere else go you know when
your spirit leaves this building you
ought to take your butt with it
and that's true of your job too and did
you hear her spirit her spirit is not in
a job anymore hasn't been there in a
long time and so let's let's lay out a
plan here get the boat up next the dock
and jump baby
get in the boat make her done i love it
that's so cool this is how it works
right here this is entre leadership
this is what we do every day inside of
this brand
and we're pumped right now we're going
to
do our summit event probably the leading
leadership event in the nation maybe in
the world and that's not an exaggeration
this is freaking incredible it's going
to be in dallas may the 16th
through the 19th and you can watch it as
a live stream it's sold out of course
but you can watch it as a live stream if
you want and uh it's got listen listen
this lineup
man this is unbelievable all the ramsey
personalities so
you know ken coleman christy wright dave
ramsey not all of us but a bunch of us
are going to be there
marcus buckingham jocko willing
i can never say jocko's last name
willink
i'm just he's fabulous he's fun craig
rochelle
pastor of life church uh pat lincione
best-selling author of the ideal team
player and many other books the
advantage everything else
good friend my good friend john
maxwell's gonna be there
john is just like he's like the grandpa
of
all leadership sorry john but you are i
love you man
we all i mean we're all like your
grandkids we all learned from you and
now we're out here teaching leadership
you're just incredible i talked to him
yesterday morning on the phone on my way
to work
and dr adrian sternberg is going to be
speaking as well dr john deloney is
going to be speaking
the lineup for this thing is
unbelievable
you want about you want to join about a
thousand other business owners watching
this online you can
three days my entire leadership team is
gonna be watching the live stream event
not working they're gonna be watching
the live stream event so that when they
get back to work they're going to be
smarter
that's how this works baby text summit
to 44222
text summit to 44222
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
so
a small business entree leadership theme
hour i'm dave ramsey your host here on
the ramsey show if you have a small
business and you have a question about
business
you want to start a business you have a
question about business you're
running a business you've got a question
about leadership we're here to talk to
you this hour
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five
two two five i started this business on
a card table in my living room and i've
grown it
with the help of a lot of wonderful
people in god's blessings
over the last almost 30 years now
to a 350 million a year business
never borrowing a dime and having an
absolutely incredible
culture inside the place it's a place
everyone wants to come to work
the people love each other they drive
for excellence we strive we argue
positively not because of politics but
we argue
because not corporate politics but we
argue
because we're fighting to win
we're fighting to be able to serve you
guys better
open phones here at 825-5225 brendan is
with us
in richmond virginia hi brendan how are
you
i'm doing wonderful thank you dave how
are you better than i deserve what's up
so my wife and i started your baby steps
back in 2019
and it couldn't accommodate a better
time because while everyone else around
us was sweating through the pandemic we
were in a better position than most
cut two here we are 20 21 my family and
i have been running a business together
since 1986
and i was looking at our finances
recently and i'm
starting to wonder where the parallels
between your baby steps
might find themselves in line with
small business finance that's a great
question
we don't use the baby steps in business
but we use the principles
that formed the baby steps to form a
financial strategy for business
now what are the principles the
principles are the easiest way to become
wealthy is to
get out of debt and stay out of debt so
i don't borrow money in business either
the principles are in the house of the
wise or stores of choice food and oil
smart people save money businesses have
retained earnings
right uh the principles are live on less
than you make
businesses need to live on less than
they make thus create a profit
um and and so these are basic principles
that we kind of all know we would call
them common sense
but how do we weave them into a business
situation then
well we're going to avoid debt number
one and that's a hard one because
there's always some kind of crap to buy
and
your personal life or in business
there's always some piece of equipment
there's always something that's going to
make it easier there's always a piece of
software there's always a new hire
there's always something that costs
money that i don't have today that i'd
like to do to move this business
tomorrow
and that temptation to go into debt is
always there would you agree with that
no for sure yeah so you've got to draw a
line in the sand and say no debt
so how are we going to do it well we're
either going to do it slower or not at
all
because we're going to cash flow this
puppy so if you've got
if you've got debt and when we're
teaching entree leadership this is what
i teach people and a thousand people 2
000 people 3 000 people in a room and
by god they're about to be there again
go figure um and so
i is i tell them you know if you've got
debt you need to put yourself
in your case it sounds like your family
is eating out of the business on
a basic living wage not minimum wage
a basic living wage and so let's say the
business is making a profit
of 300 000 and the owners are splitting
that up
don't split it up anymore live off of a
salary
until we get a retained earnings in
place and until we get
the debts cleared off and so what i tell
people to do is take your run run your
profit and loss with a salary a basic
living wage
and all profits then should be divided
uh the lion's share of the profits going
towards clearing off any existing debts
and then a smaller portion going towards
the continual building of retained
earnings and so
in my example a minute ago let's say a
200 000 profit after you paid yourself a
hundred thousand dollar salary
instead of taking home 300 we're taking
home a hundred with our salary
the other 200 then we're going to put
80 percent of it 160 000 towards debt
and 20 of it towards retained earnings
and so we got 40 000 in retained
earnings this year
and we've got 160 in debt because you're
going to need the retained earnings to
do the next thing
to avoid future debt while you're
cleaning off the old debt it's different
than the baby steps
is that logical to you it is
there are certainly parallels to it but
you know we wouldn't call it baby steps
exactly it's more of a formula but what
you do need is you need the principles
in place and
out of the principles of the principles
are debt-free live on less than you make
or save money
but then and then we're generous and so
those principles are in place and with
those then we develop
a formula where it's almost automatic
since um
let me think here 1998
four years five years after we started
the business we put the formula in place
we've never any debt
but every single month we run our profit
and loss statement and every single
month we take a percentage of that
profit
and grow retained earnings with it for
future growth
and for possible downturns we were
really glad when the pandemic hit
that there were millions and millions of
dollars in that with a thousand people
on payroll
because it became our emergency funds
that make sense
yeah and it's exactly uh well
that's one of those principles that
senior baby steps have an emergency fund
as a business a small business
uh that's absolutely essential yeah now
you've got other family members in your
business right
correct are you one of the owners or you
just work there
i'm one of the owners who owns it with
you your parents
uh so it's shared between my mother my
father and my sister
and myself so four of you are owners
okay
and can you get all of the owners on the
same page on these principles
i'm slowly getting there they have all
seen what my wife and i were able to
accomplish
in 2019 in less than in less than 10
months we're on to
baby step six excellent uh we got crazy
about it and
they looked at us a little strangely but
they get it now they're starting to
understand yeah and it's just you ask
yourself the question in business
you know when the pandemic hit if i had
no debt and had millions of dollars in
retained earnings would i feel
differently than i had millions of
dollars in debt and no money
because millions of dollars are no of
debt and no money is called
closed now they're out of business
and so those companies didn't survive
and that's the the question you ask
mom dad's sister is like look we've got
to always be ready for the upside for
growth
what's the short what's the best way to
continue to grow in good times
and when the bad times come and the big
bad wolf huffs any puffs
and he tries to blow our house in we
won't be the third pig baby
we won't be in the brick house
and um uh you know so you that's how you
get ready which is exactly what you did
at home
brendan and now you're trying to
transfer that into the business very
wise to do
very wise to do dylan is in indianapolis
hi dylan welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up in your world
all right so me and my father have just
recently
decided to open up a small business um
we do stone masonry work
um and right now i have
one builder and then another yeah
another builder that is a very good
chance for us to make a deal with them
now we're still stuck on the fact of
the marketing and making connections
with people to
get more consistent work for us and i
didn't know if you had any tips or
advice on being able to make more
connections
or stuff i could do to try to get my
name out there you know our business
and or anything like that
okay um well
the first thing i would address is i'm
not really wild about partnerships i
would prefer one of you own it and the
other one
get a percentage of the profits as their
pay
and i'm guessing i'm guessing that you
are the one concerned about marketing
your dad's more concerned about laying
stone
uh actually we both play stone i mean i
love to do it it's sort of in the blood
i didn't say you didn't know how i said
he didn't call me asking about marketing
you did
no yeah yeah that's me you're thinking
more like an owner he's thinking more
like a product guy
and that's what i'm thinking here so
anyway be careful with that that's
dangerous but
as far as marketing goes man in your
world as shoe leather i'm going job site
to job site to job site and putting my
word out
and uh putting a bid in and then once
you've done a few jobs lots and lots of
pictures
and a nice website showing your work if
you're wanting to do work for builders
it's one set of
pictures and work and details and specs
you're doing work direct to consumer
it's a whole different marketing push
and so that's what you need to decide
which or how you're going after both if
you're going after both
but it's it's straight up shoe leather
man go to the job sites
[Music]
it's a small business theme hour here on
the ramsey show
we're here to talk to you small business
people and business people about your
leadership and business questions open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five
our entree leadership summit is our
largest event of the year for business
owners and leaders it's happening
may 16 through the 19th you will not
find a bigger or better leadership event
i promise you that
it's absolutely incredible of course
i'll be teaching
marcus buckingham will be with us chaco
willink will be with us
u.s navy seal officer best-selling
author
marcus of course best-selling author of
strength finders and many other books
wonderful communicators both of these
guys along my friend craig groeschel
the founder and pastor of life church or
life.church
we used to call it lifechurch.tv i think
they're rebranding
i also started a little thing called the
youversion bible app
which has only got like a half a billion
users now
craig is an incredible leader and good
friend um
and pat lincione is going to be with us
best-selling author another good friend
and great friend of the entree
leadership
tribe all of you love pat he's always
one of our top rated speakers when he
comes
the grandpa of the leadership world
the dean of the leadership world dr john
maxwell
good friend of mine for a couple of
decades is going to be there
is always an incredible honor and
pleasure to have john speak anywhere
he is a wealth of knowledge probably
written 80 different leadership books
many many multiple best-selling books
absolutely incredible
and an incredible friend of incredible
human being dr adrian sternberg will be
with us leadership expert and speaker
she is incredible ken coleman ramsey
personality christy wright ramsey
personality dr john deloney ramsey
personality we'll all be there the event
is sold out
however you can still attend via live
stream
and you'll be joined by over 1 000
business owners and their teams who have
already registered to attend online
you can get touch with our team and uh
they will set it up to where you and
your whole team can sit and watch this
and we recommend that you set aside a
couple of days and watch
these incredible leadership think
thought leaders
incredible leadership communicators
these lessons are absolutely amazing let
me tell you what i've got 174 people
on our leadership team here at ramsey
all of them will be sitting and watching
all three days
they will not be at their desk they will
be watching all three days some of them
will be in attendance live
and some of them will be here in
nashville in our offices
and we've set aside just you know you're
you're not at work
you're at summit and you're going to be
watching the live stream
because it's too important uh i mean you
leave on fire
your team leaves on fire you get new
ideas there's nothing like an event like
this to get you moving
again especially after something like a
pandemic we need to heal and move on
right
we got stuff to do here so to register
text
summit to 4422 that's
summit to 4422
and we'll see you on the live stream uh
i'm telling you this is world-class
speaking world-class content
world-class production values this is
the leadership event in america this
year
uh and it's absolutely incredible we're
so thrilled to be in dallas
we'll be there at the at the omni uh
wonderful company to work with they are
absolutely very customer-centric
they take great care of us and we're
excited to be there with them
we were scheduled in nashville but the
nashville mayor uh comrade cooper has
got us all screwed up up here on covet
so we had to move it
and uh so we moved it to dallas and
we'll be broadcasting it from there it's
gonna be absolutely
fabulous angelo is with us in asheville
north carolina hi angelo what's up
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve how can i help
i have a couple of questions for you i'm
67 years old and i plan to retire
in perhaps two years at 70 when
i get my full social security i'm
interested in starting a miniature golf
course which would be on my main street
in my hometown which is a tourist town
i've run the numbers and everything
looks good and speaking to my wife of
43 years i hope she's not listening
because it could be 44.
but i think uh i got everything squared
away the one thing that we cannot agree
on
is who's gonna do the books so my
question to you
is dave can i just hire a retired
guy with a calculator maybe a a cpa
retiree to do my books
and does he have to come in daily to
pick up the receipts and
i have a guy who does my taxes so i
guess
at the end of the year we just bring it
over to him
so i i don't know how we could settle
that issue
who does the books what is your wife
wanting to do
she does she wants to sell the land oh
she don't do this at all
um i don't think so no well i mean
selling the land would kind of keep you
from doing it so
yeah and you know and she says if if you
do it
it's you got to do it and so she doesn't
want to get stuck
doing the books and i'm like she didn't
want you to die in her own a miniature
golf course that's what she doesn't want
yeah well sounds like my wife that would
happen that sounds like something sharon
would say sharon has figured out i'm
going to die first so
we have to plan everything that way
yeah that that could be my case too but
it's more if i want to go go ahead with
this
out number one i don't go ahead against
my wife's wishes so you need to get an
agreement on this that you're going to
put together a system by which
she has an exit strategy on this if you
pass away before she does
we're laughing about this but she's
seriously concerned about it and you
need to solve this because
very few people are successful in
business against their spouse's wishes
so we need to get to some conclusions
about i i think
i think she's probably concerned about
not running a golf course after you're
gone
so you need a way to exit her from it
if something happened to you before she
passes
and so that's thing one then thing two
to answer your question on who runs the
books
i don't want you to think that the
person that runs the books is running
the business
you've got to go run the business if
you're going to open this or you're
going to hire a manager to run the
business on a daily basis
and the manager is going to take the
receipts and put them in the bank
and and you know and and enter the stuff
into the computer
is what it amounts to right
okay and so um what kind of profit are
you projecting on this
dave i low-balled everything and had the
business running at 20
calculation 20 capacity and i figure
uh it will be open from april 1
to after thanksgiving and that's 200
days i cut it back to 150
considering weather days and i figure 69
000 net take and that is not including
t-shirts ice cream water a possible food
did you pay a staff out of that pro
forma
no who's going to run it
you're going to run it by yourself i
would like to 150 days a year you're
going to do everything there by yourself
that's not realistic well um i mean if
you get the flu the thing's closed
i see your point while you're taking
tickets at the front there's nobody
sweeping up the mess somebody made in
the back
good point so you're gonna have you need
to rethink this you need to go visit
some people that are
running miniature golf courses and see
what their staffing looks like
and and and get advice from them
somebody in a different area that's not
a com
future competitor of yours and just go
around and take a little road trip and
go visit
uh you're in asheville north carolina
run over to uh pigeon forge in
gatlinburg run over to tennessee
and there's probably 73 of them up and
down that strip and
uh you know talk to some of those guys
in those resort areas like that very
similar markets
uh very similar area you know what what
are they doing for staffing
what's their profit look like what are
they doing for their pricing model study
their businesses for best practices
and then you'll find you'll learn a
bunch that you don't know today because
you don't know what you don't know
so you need an exit strategy for your
wife you need some better best practices
to build your business on
and you're gonna have to look at your
staffing because zero staffing is
unrealistic
in a retail thing like this even in a
resort community
you're not going to want to do this by
yourself every day dude that just
doesn't sound like fun of
anything no matter how much you love it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day romans 12 12
rejoice in hope be patient in
tribulation
be constant in prayer albert einstein
said in the middle of every difficulty
lies
opportunity dave ramsey said in the
middle of every opportunity a small
business guy showed up
this is an entree leadership theme hour
thanks for joining us
and uh we want to hear about your
opportunity we want to hear how we can
help you and serve you at entre
leadership
uh we thoroughly enjoy working with and
are honored to work with business
people from all over america
particularly
small business people john is in tulsa
hey john how can we help today
hey dave it's pleasure to speak with you
today how are you
better than i deserve sir how can i help
yes sir so uh just a little bit of
background here
my wife and i are both 30 years old
we're on baby step
seven we have an opportunity to take
over a family waste hauling business
long story short i walked away from the
business
in 2014 to do some toxicity
with my father and he passed away
unexpectedly in 2015
and left it to my mom i came back to
help
run the business in 2016 and we now have
it running somewhat smoothly
she's looking at transitioning out of
the company and i'm the only one
out of uh 30 siblings that has an
interest in continuing to run the
company so my wife and i are 15
owners in the company we're not
extremely passionate about the work that
we do
but it allows us a good income uh time
off should pursue the things that we're
passionate about
the ability to give and you know i went
to school for
you know heavy equipment operation and
you know truck driving and stuff so i'm
i'm pretty good at what i do
with all that being said do you think
it's a wise choice to pursue
purchasing and running the company
and trying to make it into something
that my wife and i both enjoy
running or should we what prohibits it
from being something that you enjoy is
it what you do or how it's done
well i think my mom and i got just kind
of thrown into it uh like since my dad
passed away unexpectedly and we were
both removed from it and so
um i just i don't know if i mean you've
been running it for four years
why what is it you still don't like um
i think it's probably just more the the
people issues and things that i'm not
very skilled in dealing with i think is
probably one of my you mean your team
yes sir yeah okay well let's pretend for
a second trying to do the culture shift
yeah you it sounds like you've got some
cleanup to do yes sir
uh and you've not been able to do it due
to your ownership position
um yet but if you owned it and ran it
and you trimmed the dead wood out and
the thorns out
and you replanted and grafted in some
beautiful vines would you like running
it with people that you wanted around
i really think i would i think you know
it would be it's a profitable business
you know we're that free
and i i really i think we can make a go
out of it you know
i think you can make a go out of a lot
of stuff i'm just asking is it what you
want to do
is the toxic people situation your only
thing that's stealing your joy or is it
the general
space that you're in you just don't want
to do this every day
i think yeah i think it's more of like
the it's not necessarily toxic i think
it's just you know shifting the culture
and getting it
getting it to where you know we would uh
maybe not be as
stressed and dealing with the personnel
issues i think would probably be the
well you know here's what i will tell
you as a guy who's done this for 30
years
and again started with no team members
then i had 10 and now i got a thousand
um the folks on my team are my biggest
joy my biggest blessing
my biggest heartache yes sir
some of the stupid butt stuff some of
these people do to each other
and to me is ridiculous and then i just
have to fire them
and it just it just breaks my heart
because i love
people and i pour into them and it it's
always going to be
a source of pride
a source of love some of my best friends
work inside this building
and i i truly i mean there's some of my
best
friends and we work together we argue we
fight through things together
and then some of the meanest nastiest
things in my life have been done to me
by
employees and firmware former employees
and so it's just
and some of them claim i did that to
them which i didn't so but you know that
there's
there's all that kind of stuff that goes
that goes with the territory of managing
people
leading people there's gonna it's gonna
be a dance between the
the ugly and the beautiful and the and
the reason you know it's beautiful is
you have ugly just look at it to compare
it to
so that's gonna come but you can make it
where it you know i got
a thousand people and truly i i don't
have anybody in the building i want to
keep because i wouldn't kept on past
sundown
yes sir i i've given up on trying to
make people behave
so uh you know that is we're gonna we're
gonna work together we're gonna love
each other we're gonna treat each other
with respect and dignity
or you're not gonna be a we and uh so i
think you can do this
i think you should do this um so yeah i
think you need to start talking about
how you're gonna buy your mom out how
are you gonna do that
uh we listened to some other you know
podcasts about you know what your advice
was about you know
you know giving them a percentage of the
profits till the business is paid off
and i think that's probably the route
that we would go
good how long will that take uh
probably five to seven years maybe
you're paying her too much okay
if you're giving her the lion's share of
the profits you're living on almost
nothing
in order to clear her out and it's
taking you five years you're overpaying
her
the business is worth after salaries are
paid including your salary and her
salary because you're there
running the businesses every day after a
basic salary for you to a reasonable
salary for your two
management role is paid whatever the net
profits are
after all of that times four maybe times
five is what this is worth so you should
be done in four or five years
if you if you just live on your salary
and her salary disappears
yes sir okay you see how that formula
works out
yes sir i don't know y'all work that
through and that's fair to her by the
way and that's fair to you
um yes sir because you want this cleared
off as soon as possible in the meantime
you own 100 of it you and your wife and
you guys can begin to learn
this people skill thing and it's
the um it's the art of healthy conflict
lovingly saying this is the goal this is
the excellence mark
we're all going to work towards
excellence together i'm not perfect
you're not perfect we're all going
towards that
and we're going to treat each other with
dignity along the way and if any of you
can't do that
then you're not going to be a we because
we are doing that
yeah that's good and so and we have that
talk around here
every day every day
and sometimes somebody doesn't they they
forget it and so we have to sit down
explain to them again
this is what we're doing and we don't
talk we don't talk about each other
behind each other's back
we're not trying to cut each other's
throat we're not trying to climb on each
other's body
to the top or something like that we're
not going to use up people
we're just loving each other we're team
we're working together we're trying to
score touchdowns so we can win the
freaking super bowl
and if you're doing something other than
trying to score touchdowns to win the
freaking super bowl
you don't get to be a wii you don't get
to stay
and we're not mean or nasty or sarcastic
to people
but we will let you leave and work
somewhere else
if you decide you're stupid enough to
run to sit around and tell everybody all
your friends how
dumb you are how dumb ramsay is or your
husband or your wife's dumb enough to
tell
everybody how dumb ramsay is we'll fire
you because that's not that's not people
don't do that to people that love each
other
you don't you don't do that that's wrong
that's morally
wrong and so we will fire you and you
know you gotta you gotta be willing to
do that kind of stuff john and it's like
you're going to be on this team we're
going to work together we're going to
love each other
you're going to treat each other right
you're not going to misbehave
you're not going to make ladies be
uncomfortable in the building
you're not going to you know we're not
going to have that we're not going to
talk we don't have
it's not a matter of being woke or
politically correct or something like
that
it's a matter of loving people well and
reaching to ring the bell of excellence
together
and if we can't be unified on ringing
the bell of excellence together and if
you're going to be an impediment to that
rather than a cause of that
then you don't get to be a we we
will move you on somewhere else and if
your husband or your wife decides they
hate where you work the place that pays
you money to feed your dad gum kids
then you don't get to work here anymore
and
rooms is a cult well if you want to call
that a cult that's fine but colts don't
usually tell people to leave and we tell
them to leave pretty regularly around
here
so this is how it works folks it's a
real freaking world
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus hey it's kelly
associate producer and phone screener
for the ramsey show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
you